one of steam deck's most popular games
is coming to Game Pass a Cod leak hints
at a much beloved mode returning and
fortnite gets some crucial Star Wars
skins all on today's Gamespot news
Microsoft has announced the next wave of
Xbox game pass games arriving in
November which include a few standout
Indie Games a brand new adventure from
Obsidian Entertainment and a cult
classic IP vampire survivors one of the
most played games on valve's Steam deck
plays like an homage to Castlevania
where you slowly gather power and turn
your Supernatural Slayer into a mobile
tornado of whips cats and garlic force
fields it recently exited its Early
Access phase and is now a full release
and has been exclusive to PC until
today's game pass announcement
confirming an Xbox console release on
November 8th it's also currently on Xbox
game pass for PC released back in
October returned to Monkey Island
features series Creator Ron Gilbert back
in the captain's chair and continues the
story of The Secret of Monkey Island and
Monkey Island 2 the Chuck's Revenge the
game got a 9 out of 10 score from
Gamespot with review Richard Wakeling
noting that it feels like a quote
heartfelt and nostalgic Adventure aimed
at longtime fans of the series the game
is coming to game pass on November 10th
pentiment is the other big game for the
month a medieval murder mystery with a
distinct Illustrated style from Obsidian
Entertainment the game unfolds over 25
years during early 16th century Germany
and the entire game looks like it was
ripped from the pages of a manuscript
from that time period pentiment comes to
game pass on November 15th you can find
the full list of games announced for
game pass this month in the description
below Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 has
only been out for a few days but players
have already found a bug that allows you
to see all of the emblems and calling
cards in the game the volume of alien
themed nameplates has led some players
to believe that a Extinction style mode
may be coming to the game Extinction is
a game mode featured in 2013's Call of
Duty ghosts that pitted a group of four
players against waves of alien-like
Cryptids it has many similarities to
left the dead and its offshoots though
ghosts is one of the least successful
entries in the franchise ever Cryptids
was praised by fans as a fresh take on
the Zombies mode that have become a
staple of the franchise since Black Ops
from a beloved mode in Call of Duty to
beloved characters coming to fortnite
the Battle Royale is finally adding the
core Trio of original trilogy Star Wars
heroes Luke Leia and Han the Skins come
as a part of Skywalker week which is
kicked off and will run until November
8th during the event you're able to
round up Luke's blue and green light
savers and Darth Vader's lightsaber can
once again be earned by defeating him in
battle full details on everything to do
with the in-game event also add a link
in the description below and that is it
for today's Gamespot news which of those
Game Pass titles are you checking out in
November are you excited at the idea of
Extinction returning to Modern Warfare
2. let us know in the comments below and
we'll see you here tomorrow for more
Gamespot news
[Music]